note that with our setup this call to an
entities update function will allow each
entities unique logic function to be
called for example the landmine update
function will check against a timer each
frame to determine whether or not it
should blow up while self-destructive in
nature this type of functionality is the
backbone of our gaming system now the
game engine is capable of updating all
live entities but it's calling a blank
update method on each entity class
instance we need to fill in each
entity's update method but this might be
a little too involved for a quiz let's
instead look at a single subclass of
entity the landmine disk class
represents a landmine that's been placed
in the environment waiting for an
unknowing robot to walk on top of it we
have a couple properties that make this
possible
first off is the landmine disk actually
defines a lifetime of 100 units secondly
is we override the kill function for the
entity to remove the physics engine body
as well as the entity itself once this
landmine is dead your job if you choose
to accept it is to fill in the rest of
this update function where we subtract
0.5 from the lifetime of each update
call and then once we reach the bottom
we call the kill function and return out